hey guys gig here so this video isn't
going to be scripted and it isn't going
to be coherent but in all honesty I
don't really care because I just need to
get this out so if you haven't heard
Trey cesler aka Mr anime has been
arrested for suspicion of well they he's
been arrested and charged with murdering
and shooting and murdering his mother
his father and his brother and has also
been suspected for planning a Col Coline
type shooting on his high school now for
any of you who don't know who Mr anime M
who Mr anime is well he was one of the
first anime reviewers on YouTube I think
I think one of he was one of the first
along with I think Sheik Hardy and the
anime overviewer at least that's that's
what I remember from like years back
back in like
2006 so you might be wondering why I
give a
well actually he was one of the people
who inspired me to start doing anime
reviews I mean I sort of started doing
anime reviewing on the Heat of the
Moment and I was and that was after
seeing some of his videos and some of
like I think the anime overview
videos so if it wasn't for him I would
not be where I am now I probably
wouldn't even be on YouTube doing anime
reviews so to hear that someone who
inspired me to be where I am now did
this or at least is suspected of doing
this man oh
it it just leaves me with a really bad
feeling and a really bad aftertaste in
my
mouth I mean not only has he inspired me
he has he he actually gave me a plug a
few years back and was responsible
for one of one of pro probably one of
the only big jumping subscribers I've
had especially in my early days and I've
talked to him a few times not I don't
know him personally but I have talked to
him a few times just through private
messages and and through comments
and I I'm just I'm just completely
shocked
I I really don't know how to feel about
this and just knowing that knowing that
someone like
this had an effect on me per had a
personal effect on my life and that I've
actually talked with I'm
just oh this this is this is
up
what I can't I can't even speak properly
um I mean how how the how are you
supposed to even feel about something
like this I mean even if you didn't know
him or weren't subscribe to him this was
one of the biggest people in this anime
reviewing Community he was one of the
founding people of the community that
I'm in the anime reviewing
community
and man
just just hearing
about just hearing about this just I
just left a bad aftertaste in my
mouth
and yeah I'm I'm I'm not even sure what
I need to
say but I just needed to say something
um
yeah
I mean just for the fact that someone in
our community actually not just not just
anyone one of the oldest and the veteran
people in our community just the fact
that
someone like that who could do such an
atrocious act I mean not just killing
some random people but killing your own
family I
mean how the does this happen I
mean if you look at his videos they they
seem enough I mean he seemed like a nice
enough guy I mean it might seem like a
cliche line but I mean you really don't
know someone really do you and
just just just waiting to see how the
media are going to jump on this anime oh
anime it's it's anime's fault for doing
this I mean just just just just see how
the media twist this
into into the image of anime causing
someone to do this I mean
oh Jesus
Christ oh I
mean I I don't really know what to say
anymore I'm sorry for this completely
incoherent video where I'm just spouting
but I just I just had to get this off my
chest I mean I was planning to do I mean
I just
finished I just finished recording a new
review yesterday and I was going to plan
on finishing it finishing it tonight but
h i mean it remains to be seen if I'm in
the mood to finish an anime review so
yeah that might be delayed for a day or
two well we'll see anyway this has been
this has been gig I'm sorry for this
shitty video but hey peace